دلوقتي بيوصل للناس جوه المركز بيسالوا
على موزه يعني فعليا مش بيقولوا فين مركز
الفن فين المركز اللي فيه موزه
طبعا اكتر حاجه بتميزها ابتسامتها يعني هي
انا ما شفتش حد كده طول الوقت ما شاء الله
ابتسامه وتديكي احساس بالبهجه يعني هي
تقدر بسهوله جدا تنقل لك الانطباع ده في
الفتره الاخيره هي تقريبا
فعلا
[موسيقى]
موزه طبعا لما جت لنا ما كانتش بترسم
هي عندها اضطراب في الاعصاب ما تقدرش تمسك
الفرشه بايديها لكن بصينا على فكره ايه
اللي ممكن ان احنا نقدر نساعدها به ففكرنا
فكره ان هي ممكن ترسم برجليها فبدانا حتى
بدايه ان ازاي تمسك الفرشه بالصوابع ازاي
تتعامل معاها حجم الفرشه بدات تعمل مجموعه
لوحات خاصه
شويه والالوان والدمج يعني فعلا هي اتطورت
لو قلنا من من سنه 2017 مثلا لحد تقريبا
دي السنه السابعه لها معانا اتطورت بشكل
كتير جدا
[موسيقى]
موزه من من اكتر الناس بتعرض لوحات
بالنسبه لنا يعني موزه بتعرض مثلا في
السنه عندنا اربع او خمس معارض كل سنه هي
من اول ما بدات معنا يمكن رسمت اكتر من
اربعين او خمسين لوحه هي كل المعارضه
شاركت فيها هي معارض جماعيه مع زميلتها
وزمايلها لكن احنا فعليا البلان السنه دي
ان احنا يكون لها معرض فردي بس احنا سبحان
الله يعني كل ما نجهز معرض فردي لوحده
اتباع
منتظرين ان شاء الله نجمع مجموعه لوح
ونقفل عليها وبعدين نعمل لها ان شاء الله
معرض فردي
[موسيقى]
حاليا موزه شغاله على لوحه اللوحه من
فكرتها هي كلها مستوحاه من دماغها من
افكارها
للمره الاولى بقول ان دي لوحه او اول لوحه
الموزه بتعبر فيها عن نفسها يعني هي كانها
بتجسد شخصيه موزه جوه اللوحه فكره البنت
اللي قاعده على وجهير اللي عندها بعد
الصراعات فكره البنت اللي بتحاول فكره
الصعود او ان هي تقوم او ان هي بتتحدى اي
شيء بيقابلها جنب صعوبات في الحياه ده كله
ظهرت له اللوحه بشكل جميل جدا وبتتشاط
مميزه جدا
[موسيقى]
انا حابب اقول ان الفن بالنسبه لموزه انا
بعتبره حياه يعني هي بصت لفكره الفن او ان
هي تعمل عمل فني ان هو ده اللي حقق لها
ذاكره هو ده اللي خلى ليها قيمه جوه
المجتمع
[موسيقى]
مؤمن طبعا